so hi my name is or and actually I'm
really glad to be here it's my first
time in London and at PI data so it's
been great weather so far and I hear
this is not common so I'm happy to be
here my talk is really centered about
a/b testing and our implementation of it
we're going to go through some things so
out of curiosity who here is a software
developer and works actively on this we
here has ever run a Navy experiment who
would like to run an a/b experiment yeah
that sounds about right okay so let's
learn a little bit more I come from Yelp
based in San Francisco so all the way
over here and our mission is to connect
people with great local businesses I
don't know how many of you have used it
who here is heard of or used yelp okay
so good I'd not to from so one of the
things is is that we have millions of
users right we've had ten years full of
content generated by lots of users and
that creates a lot of reviews and a lot
of data for us to work with and every
time we work on new features or new
components we can start to use this data
to learn from now my team has added a
new component so we are the transaction
platform team and here we're looking at
a normal yelled business page and you
can see here wing wings which is a local
San Francisco delicacy for wings and
this is the component that we added
which is a way for users to directly
order food from their local businesses
now this is a full fledge of back-end
services to run this entire service of
being able to order for mood and being
able to get it delivered and you can
imagine just adding this to page isn't
like everything that you need there's a
little host of systems behind this but
what we're going to deal with is that we
wanted to know how do we keep improving
this experience for the user and how do
we keep improving our conversion because
in a lot of ways bun clicks on ads or on
things like this will generate directly
to revenue so not only are we connecting
users in a new manner but we're also
generating revenue in a new way for you
so a year ago we started looking at a be
experiments for our team now we're
mostly back in engineers so we didn't
have a lot of expertise in a big
and we weren't sure do we have enough
users do we have a lot of time what's a
trade-off between running this
experiment and these set of experiments
that we would love to run and working on
a new feature so which would be better
which would be worse so we started this
as a simple investigation to start with
and the main thing is that going to our
project manager and asked them they even
for a first idea of what we could do as
an a/b test is not a problem at all
you're in terms of people who deal with
the product they would love a lot of
variations to be run it would have a lot
of ideas of what else could be changed
right so it's always a trade-off between
experimentation feature work and
continuously building on improvement so
what we saw is that over the course of
this simple investigation we ran a set
of three experiments and we connected
our users and we improved our system and
we saw a total of fifteen percent
increase in revenue so what we're going
to talk today is about these set of
cases of our three experiments that we
ran I'm going to dig deeper into how we
run our experiments how we phase this
whole thing and then how we saw the
improvement from this so with that let's
talk a little bit about what is a Navy
experiment so I'm sure you all
understand vagal you bite a navy
experiment does any time that you start
with two variations right and you're
comparing them now of course then the
question is when do you run this well
any time you can phrase a question so
here we could phrase is green going to
do better than orange is a green going
to do worse than orange that's a time
you can run a navy experiments its
entire process to putting a scientific
method to your experiment ation so you
can create a question then you can
create a way of doing this now why the
more data you have the better you can
make a decision the more you can
understand the impact of your any work
that you do and you can understand how
that impact could affect you long term
and this is why we keep running a be
experiments and something why we always
want to keep running a big
experimentation so with that I want to
talk about how and this is really the
meat of this talk and we're going to go
through these steps so the first step to
creating an a/b experiment is to have
that question what are you going to be
testing and from understanding that
question you're going to need to get all
the
cessary background data that's anything
from click-through rate to getting
traffic results to being able to know
how much traffic you're going to need
and doing sample size calculation next
you're going to need to implement this
and test it code doesn't just magically
appear right so we have to do some work
to do this so we're going to implement
our a B experiment and create our
framework and then we're going to test
to make sure that everything is working
appropriately next we're going to roll
it out you know pretty explanatory on
this right the main thing is that you
get a good way of testing out any things
in production as well as actually
ramping up to your necessary length and
then finally you'll wait the period of
time and you'll get to analyze your
results so with that let's dig into our
first case study greener pastures so we
start first by generating our hypothesis
right now let's look at our page right
this is when wins again and remember
this is our widget so if we went to our
product manager and we asked them how do
we make this better one of the pretty
standard maybe experiments is bun colors
right we looked about this before right
the simple variation could be your
orange and green but you can do a lot
more things one thing could do is we
could actually make this bun bright red
and just constantly flashing all right
this would get a lot of user attention
right we're pretty sure if I put
something on there that's just
constantly blaring at your face you're
going to probably at least click on it
or look at it but that's probably going
to be a pretty bad user experience
overall and it's probably going to
negatively affect the rest of the page
which is actually something that a bee
experiments would let us measure but
let's not get there to first so the
first thing is we're going to look at
this weight so our product manager
consider this ok bun colors of standard
a bee experiment so what color should we
change this button too well green right
greens the color of money green
successful green means go so you're
going to want to click that button now
ok that's a understandable statement so
now we have a question is green going to
perform better than orange we've created
a hypothesis now just to make this is
one variation
so even though I did change the header
text to be completely back this is
entire thing is considered one variation
okay so still it's as a unit we made a
change so that's okay now next step is
gathering all your necessary data we
need to understand are some simple
things so what kind of data are we
looking for the first thing is is going
to be the click-through rate how much
are people clicking the button currently
you know this is going to be our
baseline conversion number and this is
going to be everything that our
experiment is going to be testing to see
if we can improve this conversion number
so we need to understand what is
currently our reality next you're going
to need to measure your weekly traffic
how many people are seeing this button
even and how many people are clicking on
it you need to know how long this
experiment is going to need to run and
from that you're going to need to know
how long how many people are seeing this
now what else are we going to
potentially look at a be experiments are
great because they allow you to measure
a lot of secondary metrics anything else
on that page we can measure and know the
impact of our experiment on those
secondary metrics so let's go a little
bit in specifics for this experiment so
our key metric is again that click
through conversion rate so how many
people are looking at the business page
and then clicking on start order our
primary our secondary metric is going to
be conversion we are looking at total
orders placed so that means you click
start order then you add an item to your
cart and then you actually checked out
so we're caring about making sure that
the reason people are clicking on that
button isn't just because we made it
bright red and now everyone just clicks
on it to see what it is it's actually
because we're getting more people to
notice it that have the intent to
actually order food makes sense right we
want to make sure that if you're getting
into the funnel you're actually going to
complete through the funnel so we want
to see that increase alternatively we
can also add measure things like ads on
that page or other potentially important
secondary metrics for us are things like
reviews on that page you know if we made
it bright red and flashing you could
imagine everything else would have been
negatively impacted so an a/b experiment
would allow us to measure those
secondary metrics really well but we
think this is going to be green is okay
it's not going to over like take an
effect on everything so we're going to
measure those secondary metrics but
that's not
the most important thing we want to care
about this order completion okay so now
we need to a little bit of mouth pretty
expired we're going to use a minimum
detectable effect of five percent that
means that we're going to want to see a
relative increase in our conversion by
five percent to say that this experiment
is statistically significant we're going
to use a statistical power of
ninety-five percent which is on the high
end you know industry standard is eighty
percent but we wanted to run this
experiment to understand really well
that we were making a change to be
impactful right this is investigating
how a be experienced so we wanted to
have a very high statistical power and
we're going to use a standard
significance level of five percent okay
running a little bit of math we're going
to use some sample size calculations and
we're going to get that we're going to
need about three hundred thousand users
/ variation okay so now if we make an
assumption that we get a million users a
week which you know Yelp gets a lot more
than that but we're going to make that
then you can consider that this
experiment would be run within one week
right because you're going to need half
to be in a control group and have to be
in your variation and I'm going to talk
about that a little bit more later well
okay great now we need to implement this
all right we know how to code let's work
on this so as I said we're going to need
to keep a control group control group is
going to be really important for a
couple of reasons one we want to measure
our baseline conversion not on our past
data but on our current data and this
keeps our control this way we know what
our users are doing constantly and make
sure that there's no negative no change
with food orders there's a lot of
seasonality a be experimenting will let
us know that our change is the reason
that we saw an increase or decrease
right so we want to know that it's the
change itself that's making that impact
and not some other underlying cause and
by keeping a control group we can tell
what the current conversion rate is for
there's a day or week so it's important
to keep a control group always when you
run an a/b experiment right a B so make
sense so we're going to do fifty percent
for each you could do more or less we
just did this because make sense we're
going to split it evenly so that we can
make sure that we're investigating it
correctly okay next some little bit of
code right you're actually going to need
to run this um
a Yelp there a lot of other experiments
are running from search from actually
other teams that are constantly working
and one of the things is that they're
basically a giant dictionary for every
user the current requests into what
experiment are you being bucketed and we
don't want to constantly have to query
this giant dictionary so instead we're
going to use quarks so that way in our
code we're only caring about our
experiment the other benefit is that
then you get actual default so you can
say within this it makes your testing
better and makes it a lot easier and
makes it compact okay makes sense all
right test testing is very important of
course it's important but it's really
important when you're doing a Navy
experiment you want to make sure there's
no bugs in your code you want to make
sure that there's nothing going wrong
and not just in your code but also
visualization right when you're actually
making this change to the button you
want to make sure it's proper right
changing the CSS to make it green is
simple but you want to make sure that
you're able to see both the orange and
the green now right if you said that
your by using cards right you could said
that you are now in the default
variation you should be make sure that
your output is getting orange if you're
in the enabled group you should make
sure that you're seeing green so you
want to make sure you're testing this
you want to make sure that the entire
workflow is working correctly and that
the colors output it correctly okay now
we get to roll this out so for us we
roll it out in a couple steps first we
do internal roll out make sure there are
no bugs we make sure that there's
nothing wrong then we'll go to very
small percentage of traffic for a short
period of time to see the enabled this
just gets us a little bit more
validation that we're still in seeing no
bugs in our experiment if we do see
something that's wrong we can always try
an experiment off and then not let
anybody see the enabled variation and
then fix our code and then roll back and
then we roll straight to our
predetermined traffic percentage of
fifty percent okay so now let's say we
do this we have now run our experiment
and now we can wait and get our results
so we come back and it's been a week and
we see something we've got a five point
two six percent relative increase which
is fantastic this actually means that we
had an experiment be successful right we
were looking for a five percent
increase so anything above that means
that we had a statistically significant
effect so green is better than orange
fantastic so you can now go and tell
your p.m. this and he is super excited
right now he can go and keep going on
all the experiments he has plenty of
ideas for what else they run and now we
have a new issue we have an abundance of
experiments so you can imagine right
instead of now one thing that they want
to change there's a hundred things that
they can change and each one of those
that can come up with five different
variations for them right so we're
actually have a lot of experiments now
that our pm's want to run well let's
think about this we know how to do that
let's go through it first thing first
we're going to need to have our
hypothesis what are we testing in all
these experiments so first rpm came up
with a good idea they want to take the
button color and they want to look at it
again and they want to make sure that it
wasn't just that we change the color
that was better we want to make sure
that we got the best color that we could
have so we're going to run this with
multiple colors now and each one is
going to have its own amount and we're
going to see which color is best was it
green that was actually better or was it
just that we got rid of orange could it
be red or blue that actually makes us
the big impact okay makes sense and
another thing they want to run so here's
the business page again now in the
English language which most of our users
are the way that you see and the way
that you read things is in an F shape so
like this right you read from left to
right and top down now if you notice our
widget is outside of the F so this means
that not a lot of users are probably
paying attention to it just because of
its location so let's take this and
change the layout and move it to the
left so we're going to move it
everything to the left that was on the
right so that now it for sits firmly
inside that F shape okay that makes
sense we're going to use just simple
psychology to make it so that people are
seeing our bun far more by the location
okay okay that makes sense so now we
need to run our next step we've got to
gather the necessary data we actually
have a big advantage here since we're
testing on exact
name component as we were before we
actually have the same data to use from
last time we know the exact same
baseline conversion that we just ran on
and we know what our weekly traffic rate
is but we're going to do a little bit
more that layout change for example it
touches a lot of things on that page so
we want to make sure that we have a lot
of secondary metrics that we are going
to measure we're going to actually check
everything on that page see the
conversion rates on other components as
well as ads are on that page you know
revenue still is generated mostly
through ad so we want to make sure that
we're not negatively impacting our ads
conversion okay so there's one more
thing that needs to be changed since we
now have multiple variations for our
color experiment we're actually going to
need to do a little bit of refactoring
and recalculating are very number of our
sample size and this is just a simple
correction and all you need to do is
update your alpha value for the number
of variations that you're running ok now
we'll implement this so same thing as
before we're going to create a couple
more if statements we're going to have a
number more bucketing you know we have
five colors now we have to lay out okay
and now let's run this but Oh leave that
an issue you can actually now be left in
green not only can you be left in green
you actually have the full set of things
that can happen we have five colors and
we have two layouts and all of these can
be combined and now we're going to have
an issue before we were just measuring
two things now we thought we were going
to measure five and two we actually now
have ten so having to measure 10
different variation is going to make it
so that our experiment is going to have
to run far longer right and you can
imagine if we were to run a third
experiment or a fourth experiment on
this underlying component it's going to
multiply the number of variations that
we're running so this is an issue
because now it's going to take us a lot
longer to run our right because each
variation needed that amount that we
calculated from the sample size so
having more variations is going to make
it so take a lot longer so we can go
back to our p.m. and tell them hey
that's not going to work we can run
everything sequentially but now we're
back to only running one experiment at a
time and that seems like not okay
right we should be able to do more than
one experiment at a time right we this
seems like something we can solve so we
came up with something called swim lanes
and this is the way that we got about
this so let me rewind and explain a
little bit about what that means this is
currently what we have right you have an
experiment it's off or on right orange
or green we have our second experiment
left and right this is the reality right
now right there overlapping because
they're running simultaneously and the
way that that would be spread is you
know not significant so we could measure
all that but we don't want to do that
because it gets a lot more complicated
right we have a lot more variations that
we would need to measure and this
doesn't scale very well so we're going
to think about this like a pool in a
pool every swimmer has their own lane
and every time they swim they're not
running into the other people because
they stay in their own lane right so
similarly we're going to do that for
experiment each one is going to get
assigned a lane and the users in that
will be then divided as they were before
so this lets us pre-define our users
into experiment and assign them Elaine
this allows for us to control which
experiment you're in and which you're
not which means that we're actually
running experiments exclusively for one
another and this has a couple of
advantages so we're going to see it like
this an experiment let's say gets the
top lane top two lengths for our
experiment four colors and bottom two
for layout so if you are assigned to
lane one you're going to be an orange if
you're assigned to lane to you're going
to be green you're not going to see left
and right you're only going to see the
color change because you're in staying
in that swim lane so we're going to
pre-partition our experiments so that
way you're not seeing them
simultaneously so that's the way that
we're going to get by this so now
instead of multiplying the number of
variations we're only adding them
because each one has been pre-assigned a
swim lane okay so this means right that
the length of time for running our
experiments gets cut waved down right
because instead of having five times two
it's now five plus two so now it's only
somewhere and you think how this scale
is how when you start to run more and
more experiments right it's not
multiplicative it's additive so that
makes it a lot better okay there's
another advantage we can now actually
when we were starting experiments right
because if we try to run them and have
10 variation you think we need to start
this from the beginning because
otherwise you're going to have some very
messy data to deal with of when one
experiment started one another one
started how did they affect each other
how do they not affect each other
instead we're very much isolated each
experiment is its own food group and we
have each one to start and end at seven
times so a different developer can work
on a different experiment a different
person can work on it you can stagger
the times you can analyze them on their
own you never have to worry about all
the times that you did it when did this
one start one to the next one start how
did they mesh up how did the data get
affected so it makes it a lot easier in
that way but we have some trade-offs
right so we're now getting testing is a
little harder so instead of having only
an experiment be enabled and disabled
it's now enabled disabled or not
existent right so we want to make sure
that our default case from fear not in
the experiment is what we expect it to
be right so let's look a little bit of
about the code I had before before I was
checking if you were in our status quo
or our control group and setting it to
orange well you can imagine now if your
experiment is none you're seeing green
and that's not what you wanted right we
wanted our default case I if you're not
in the experiment to stay too orange ok
so we want to make sure that we're
always actually assessing it by which
cohort that you are enabled in so you
could imagine right you'll have if it's
green if it's blue if it's red right
always going down so signing
specifically to what you want and having
a same default to the end which is what
we expect it to be ok so now we roll
this out and the first thing we want to
make sure is that we actually got the
right way that we actually did our swim
lanes correctly so it's for us we had
when we implemented this we had to
actually measure our swim lanes behaving
correctly and testing that as well
otherwise we would have actually still
seen all of that cross variation so we
measure correctly that we actually split
out our traffic correctly but then at
that point it's now simple we're back to
just running a B experiment and
measuring them so now we get to analyze
a result you wait a little bit and we
got back and it's great Green definitely
is the winner
it's a far greater success and you can
imagine that we actually saw a big
improvement from this from having to
experiment seeing this increase in terms
of a minor thing if you look at the
error bars there's just a slight overlap
with that dark orange color and you can
imagine yourself do you run another
experiment now of comparing the green to
that dark orange well at this point you
can always keep experiment but we
actually made a product decision of this
is good enough we've seen green do very
well for two experiments in a row and we
can decide that we're going to continue
with just having green for now and then
maybe in the future we can come back to
this decision but now we have the data
to tell us that green is statistically
significantly better than orange and we
can now consider running these other
colors and how their impact and if we
will ever wanted to revisit this
decision we can see why we made it as
well as what could be our effect for
running up a follow-up experiment in
terms of the layout it's just as
expected moving things to the left saw a
huge increase everything that got moved
to the left side so not only our button
but everything else here got at least a
ten percent increase and click-through
rate and some even saw as much as twenty
and twenty-five percent so no no
surprise there you know seeing things
move to the left is it the way that
people in the English language just read
so it just became far more prominent in
their in their visualization but there
was something that happened negatively
everything that got moved to the right
now saw a decrease and primarily what
the things that are there is our ads our
ads got shifted to the right and saw a
drop now at this point you can consider
have we seen enough revenue increase
from our continuing getting orders
compared to our ads and we didn't so at
this point we were like okay this
experiment will not be rolled out in its
current format we're going to go back to
the drawing board redo this layout and
then we run this as a follow-up
experiment and it was thanks to doing
this as an a/b experiment that we could
understand very well the impact of this
change before we would have been able to
tell us that it was specifically the
left-hand change which caused this drop
in our ads so swim lanes made it so that
we could tell exclusively that it was
our lay
which caused this impact so with that I
hope you now have a far better
understanding of how to run a Navy
experiment and even though it is a
little harder than just changing the CSS
of it a button it's actually really
doable and you can manage that
complexity for when you try to run
multiple experiments for us we use swim
lanes as the way that we can run
experiments exclusively so that way we
can test the same underlying component
at the same time now that doesn't mean
there aren't other solutions but in
terms of a this is the best way that
we've gone with in terms of getting a
lot this experiment so we again we ran
just three experiments for investigating
and we saw a 15-percent increase in our
revenue from then we've actually kept on
running a lot more experiments we've
seen a really big impact in our
understanding of our features as well as
an understanding of our users by running
these experiments so with that I'd like
to say thank you yes no no so yeah so in
terms of the way we run this
everything's actually custom the the
majority of this implementation is all
via request so everything is done by
bucketing on the requests so that way
you're assigned an experiment variation
when you start a request there are
off-the-shelf solutions for this we are
still in the works of actually open
sourcing our solution but that's farther
down the line at the moment but the main
point is that you can actually do a lot
of this by just going through the steps
of the bucketing yourself and you can
consider that you make sure that you
measure this appropriately yes
yeah so let me answer that first
question and then I'll get to your
second one okay so the question was in
terms of how do I know that the how do i
define what my Intendant increases and
then how do I measure from there what it
is so all of that is actually done right
when we do our calculations so at this
point right at this point is where we
actually decided that we're trying to
reach for five percent this just as
easily could have been a minimum
detectable effect of three two or ten
right so at that point we're actually
making the measurement for how many
users we're going to need to see so if
we ran an experiment with a five percent
minimum detectable effect and we saw a
ten percent increase then we are
definitely successful if you see a five
percent as your bar for success and you
see that you only get three percent then
according to your definition your
experiment was inconclusive a little bit
of practice and actually we do multiple
calculations so every time you change so
if you have a lower number the length of
time of your experiments is going to be
higher if you make your number too low
everything is going to need to run
forever so maybe it's not worth it for
you to make that change so five percent
is a pretty good you actually saw
success if you go below to your probably
shouldn't be running that experiment
because it's too low of an impact right
but this is the the frequent us apart if
you get the five percent you've
definitely and you have enough users
then you've definitely were
statistically significant
right there are different approaches for
how you can deal with that right
right so there's a couple so running
things like that you actually can but
then you can't see the exclusive changes
of one experiments effect so for example
in our case if we had run it like that
we wouldn't have been able to say so so
strongly that just by moving things to
the left you saw a negative impact in
ads right but what if left and green has
a different effect than left in blue and
right and green has it doesn't work
exactly you have to do a lot more math
actually the other thing is you have
each one of your variations is going to
need this many users so you're going to
need to run your experiment longer so
instead of having eight we ran down to
seven right which granted 827 you don't
see a lot but when you run for five
experiments at the same time it starts
to quickly scale up to being you now
have 20 or you know you have a far
greater number of variations that you
need to do calculations for so it is
doable but it's a very different
approach and that's not the one that we
want to go down yes the team structure
and the ocean so who is actually owned
in the experiment do you complain
science to analyze engineering product
manager so can you just elaborate yeah
so in terms of our team you know yelp
has a data science a group we have an
entire p.m. organization as well as like
PM's assigned to teams of engineers for
us the data scientist is really a little
bit more of consulting in terms of this
you know we have this approach for
running an experiment during this
process of investigation we were working
very closely with the data science team
to make sure that everything that we
were doing as we were learning was
appropriate but following running these
like three experiments we now only check
with them you know a lot less frequently
because we know what our approaches
unless we're doing something a lot more
crazy but we can just follow this same
routine and just go through these steps
and crank out experiments and then
individual engineers are the ones who
are owning the individual experiments
because they're running exclusively you
can actually control it so that way each
engineer is just responsible for their
experiments
they make sure to coordinate like when
experiments are running and how much do
you need for traffic but otherwise it's
very much individual ownership and then
the product side of it is very much like
helping the side before the experiment
has launched what are intended that's
where we like okay what do we expect as
as our effective increase from this what
r is this a good experiment after I run
some simple calculations will this be a
good enough experiment for us to run
right now or is this not going to be
effective compared to some other feature
that we need to work on yes yes yeah so
in terms of where are ya yeah so the
question is is how do you make the how
do you make the decision of what the
incremental changes are for your ABA
experiments and how does that go with
the long-term vision of the product
correct so the long-term vision of the
product is really what drives these are
a be experiments you know for us we care
about you know increasing the amount of
orders so for us this is the main
product how do we keep improving this
how do we keep improving the user
experience and you know the bottom line
at the end because this affects directly
revenue so that user experience is what
we're caring about improving so a navy
experiments of how do we start with
getting more users into the funnel is
where you can consider that you know
what the incremental changes are we want
to run a lot of a B experiments actually
we actually want to go at a very quick
rate of launching and starting and
completing experiment so that way we
have a better understanding of you know
how a new feature might have an impact
as a simple prototype of you know a
simple button instead of the full
fledged feature so for us we're able to
use a be experimenting to really ramp up
our speed of actual development because
we can do a short amount of time in an
a/b experiment or we can do a longer
amount of time in a simple feature AV
experiment so that's how we do this in
terms of making sure that it fits within
our long-term vision and then go through
very incremental changes to get there
so for for these sorts of experiments
it's all in the request side so we do
basically a random so when you generate
a new request you'll get a cookie that
has and then you're from there you're
assigned into a variation after a
certain period of time that cookie gets
refreshed then you get reassigned yes
yes right so the question is have we
done any consideration into automation
of running all these experiments and
then launching new ones and changing on
top of that yes it's actually a very big
project you can imagine any sort of
automation on and a result of an
experiment is actually very complicated
you need to understand the impact of
what that experiment is and understand
it in the case of like for example that
layout change that experiment was a
success it's on nine point three percent
increase which is more than five percent
you can imagine that could keep getting
better but it has a negative impact on
ads which for us is still more important
so it gets complicated in terms of
figuring out a larger set of metrics
that you will then need to say how an
experiment overall is doing and then
understand will that need to be is that
good enough to roll out completely or
does it actually require more changes
before it's gone into production and the
reality is a lot of time that's a lot
easier to just do by person you know
there's actually a lot of conversations
about how the product will change and
what experiment you want to keep running
afterwards rather than automating the
full thing but we are working on
automating you know a lot of this
process in terms of the calculation and
in terms of just those simple launches
so turn off and turn it on yes
right so the question is is what is the
advantages of the swim lanes compared to
an alternative such as a banded approach
or a more patient approach so as I was
saying the the swim lanes allow for us
to exclusively see an experiment at a
time we wouldn't have been able to tell
you that the left side cause the
negative impact to ads if we did a
banded approach so being able to make
really strong assessments and strong
statements about your experiments is
some of the advantages of an a/b
experiment right you'll know your
secondary metric impact from your
experiment and running them all at once
you know the calculations become more
more difficult so running them
individually in a way allows for it to
be a lot easier for you to understand it
allows for developers to keep working
them at the same time and not worry
about their impact on a separate
experiment in terms of the Bayesian
approach that has more to do with the
analysis and calculation rather than
actually your approach to launching an
experiment and we are actually using a
more patient approaching now it's been a
year since we started this but it was
just at the time it was a lot easier for
us to start like this yes
so the question is why do we define our
experiment variation assignment by
visitor rather than customer and a lot
of that is actually based that how do
you define a single customer is actually
a very difficult question especially for
something like Yelp where you have users
who are on mobile on desktop on
potentially a lot of different devices
at the same time and instead of trying
to always say that you are one user and
you're going to be in all these
experiment it's a lot easier just to be
this visit this visit this visit that's
why we actually do session so it's not
like when you visit you are stuck you
will be bucketed and you'll stay on that
until for a very long period of time so
you're it's not just on the like every
time I refresh the page I'm going to be
in a new bucketing so that's how we
approach it so it's not just like a
exactly per visit but it's a long-term
per visit sort of approach yes
right right so so the question is in
terms of the transaction length compared
to the length of the experiment if you
have a very long transaction left from
when you're considering starting a
transaction to when you actually want to
complete then your experiment will need
to either run longer to capture more
time or you'll need to discard some of
the initial data because the users would
have been affected by your experiment
from the beginning because for us it's a
lot of food orders as you can imagine
the time that you order for food is for
tonight for the next hour at six o'clock
right now I'm hungry I want to order
some food it's not a it's a very quick
decision-making process it's not a
transaction that you need to worry about
for the next week right so it makes it
so that we can constantly keep
experimenting on our users which is a
really big advantage so it is important
to always take into account the way that
your users are using your product and
the way that you need to approach it for
them anything else yes
so for us it's a lot less with marketing
it's a lot more of understanding how the
product so as I said that ninety-five
percent is a far higher significant
threshold than normal a be like the
industry standard is only eighty percent
so we were keeping it at that higher
threshold because we were doing initial
investigation I wanted to make sure that
we have a very good understanding so
that we could say with very strong
confidence this experiment is working
when when we really working with our
product people and our data scientists
they have a pretty they've started to
develop this understanding of what does
your confidence mean how strong is this
experiment but a lot of times it really
come that question comes up when an
experiment is borderline successful or
has negative impact while being
successful for example and at that point
it really isn't about the the
significance it's more about the impact
so a lot of times it's more about
understanding your impact on that bottom
line when we saw the left hand change
you know we saw in a ten percent
increase in our click-through rate but
we saw a drop down in our ads revenue so
that outweighed the current decision
right so then they understood okay we
need to go back we need to consider how
would we better do a layout for this
page so that way we can under this
process again and get an impact that's
advantageous to everybody makes sense
foundation
yeah so the question is about how do we
prioritize the new experiments and how
do we kind of go about the the
trade-offs between a new experiment and
change and a new feature and the reality
is is that we can actually even do new
feature releases as a Navy experiment
which allows for us actually get a
better understanding of how those will
affect and usually from from full
features you actually see a much bigger
than five percent increase so it makes
it very quick to run an experiment that
just like a quick validation what else
is getting is there anything that got
negatively impacted which makes it so
that way we can just roll out features
in a very controlled way in terms of
just general like improvement so styling
sort of changes we do this the first two
steps of the ABA experiments to really
get us the understanding of how long
will it take and then we can go back to
product and tell them this is what we
expect if we assume a five percent
increase and assume using our just you
know going through what's our current
traffic analysis this is how long an
experiment going to run two weeks four
weeks is it going to run it's going to
take a six months that's then they
product can go back and be okay well if
it's going to take a six months right
now but what if instead we built this
first feature then would it go through
and then it drops down two months they
can make the better prioritization of
build this first build this next test
this out afterwards so really going
through the process even if it's the
first couple of steps it's very short it
gets you a good understanding of what
you're currently looking at it gets you
a good understanding of what the
question that you want to ask and it's
really helpful to like go back to
product with that understanding we've
actually gone through and made an entire
document of like write up what your
experiment is planned to be and just
going through those steps have a lot of
let for a lot of engineers to make a
good understanding of what they're like
potential trade offs are and having to
go through and know Oh actually I'm not
even measuring my my primpin right now
can't tell you what our conversion rate
it so sometimes you just need to go
through that first two steps so that way
you can understand and then you can
approach through it and then prioritize
appropriately let's have a nor for this
great dog for coming all the way from
California thank you